when i watched this movie i did not
leave it thinking oh
i can't wait to watch 11 year olds do
that again i left it thinking when i
raise my kids i don't think i ever want
them to join a dance troupe
today's topic cuties you guys want us to
cover this
cuties the movie oh i thought you were
talking about like
good looking chicks and stuff what i'm
talking about is like you know when you
playing in the wrong playground and you
get caught
and they're like yo what are you doing
here and you're like cuties
so this is a very controversial topic
it's a movie that came out and it's
basically
took the internet over there's a whole
bunch of hashtags to cancel netflix
because the movie's controversial
involving 11 year olds okay so a couple
disclaimers one there's going to be
big spoilers in this and the reason why
is in order to contextualize
aspects of the movies that everyone is
critiquing i need to give the context of
what's happening in the story
to decide whether or not the scene
itself is justifiable or not
and the second thing is come into this
with an open mind when we're having this
conversation i know it's charged
but please don't come at it all crazy
it's kind of like you know when i'm
talking about
trans related stuff and people are like
i'm fighting for my existence i'm like
boo boo i can't talk to you
if you're just being like we're trying
to protect it i get it let's have this
conversation try to be calm let's try to
dissect this information
how i'm going to approach this is i'm
going to separate this in two parts
first
there's the marketing of the film and
then there's the film itself
okay because the first wave of criticism
that came but came before the movie even
came out yeah
it was a poster came out and everyone
freaked out and justifiably so so
when it comes to the marketing of the
movie i agree 120
it's like the way they presented the
poster the post that they used
the american poster that they used
really didn't portray the movie and
really use the most offensive part to to
to lure you in which is kind of
a silly way to do it it's almost as if
they wanted to do that
yes like outrageous marketing yes they
absolutely wanted people to talk about
it yeah and guess what
it worked they wanted people to talk
about it right so
yes i agree with you the marketing a bit
trash whenever there's something that
happens like the h
m and whatever all the flops that
happened in marketing
and they're like oh sorry we didn't know
and they made these [ __ ]
like excuses and i'm like you studied
years and years plus the trends
of what's going on with the different
marketing and you didn't know
and you didn't know like you that is
actually
what you do i i was in college
and i had a class but we had to i don't
remember the name of the class but the
point of the class
is it was to analyze publicity and
analyze
different movies example the movie sixth
sense
we had to analyze it and see what the
meanings of everything in the movie was
because movies are just not
are not just movies like that example in
the sixth sense the color red the color
red means
death everything that is red in the
movie means
death and it's and it's made like that
the door handle the dress of the mother
is red
the balloon that goes up the ceiling
everything before he sees dead people
is read in that movie so
so so publicity and marketing works like
that
they work many many years to perfect
so the fact that oh no it was just a
slip up you don't believe that i
really don't buy it at all
i'm not mad at you and i think also when
you consider what the original poster
looked like compared to the north
american one
the difference is astounding like when i
looked at the original picture honestly
it just looked
it looked a little silly there's nothing
flagrant about no right it's like four
girls
fully dressed running down the street
but the marketing was done for who
a european market oh okay yeah yeah
the north american one had to be
flagrant and so
that was the the choice that kind of
confused me there and that's why i think
when you put out an image like that and
you don't and the description that he
gave was very
minute and did represent the movie after
having watched it
i thought it was odd that they did
something so flagrant and added such a
small description
and so in that regards netflix deserves
all the criticism that it's getting
because i'm like you can't be mad at
people for not getting the full context
when you
put out a trailer and you put out an
image that doesn't
have any context to it i can't be mad at
them
i can't be mad and that's hence the
reason why i go with what i was
you know what i mean yeah it was on
purpose yes so now comes the second part
now it comes to the actual film the film
came out recently
and um i saw a whole bunch of commentary
you know what really confused me i won't
lie to you
is i saw a lot of people reviewing the
movie having never watched it
which seems to be like a trend now if
you're going to critique the film
it's much better if you watch it so that
you can properly dissect it and point
out every point that's negative
but if you don't even watch it you can't
participate in this conversation in a
meaningful way whether you're for or
against it
if you want to really dissect this movie
and throw it in the garbage you'll have
to actually see to know what it's about
even like youtubers large questions
absolutely i watched your video and i'm
like okay
like disclaimer i didn't watch it well
i'm like then why are you reporting this
to me the video ends there right you
can't give me a review what's happening
in the movie and the little clips that
you saw and like no that's not how it
works
and so i took the time to watch the
movie now if you don't want to support
by paying for it
look i didn't support i torented and
then from there i was like alright cool
you know what i mean you could pirate
all right
am i going to watch you know am i going
to pay to watch kids get sexualized no
but if it's free
i'm open to it me and preach come from a
dance background like i've been dancing
for
over 10 years now preach probably way
longer than me yeah and i judged
competitions
when i saw the outfits that everyone was
freaking out over i'll be honest with
you guys
this is literally what you see at every
dance recital i can pull up videos on
youtube right now
of dance recitals all across this
country all across the u.s all across
europe
girls are dressing like that every
single day i'm talking about even when
they go to dance classes
you see girls eight seven eleven twelve
dress like that every single day pop in
an episode of dance moms
what they make those kids wear is way
more revolting
than even what those girls were wearing
in that movie am i lying nope
makeup and everything there are twerk
teams that you can find right now
on youtube with millions of views
millions of likes no hubba when i saw it
in the dance world i didn't like it
personally i thought that they were
over-sexualizing young children
in order to prop them up as dancers and
basically they would push these girls
and say this how you have to dress
in order to win this competition this is
how you have to just and i've always had
a problem
it's a conversation that me preach or
other friends who dance have had
like yo i have an uncomfortable feeling
watching certain dances absolutely
because of how these kids are being
forced to dress or how they feel like
they have to dress
now this is a conversation that we've
been having for years
four years so when i pop in this movie
i'm expecting it to glorify
and to my surprise it does the opposite
i'm gonna give you guys the plot
um basically this is a senegalese family
they're just immigrating to france
and uh the mom arrives with her two kids
without her
her husband and she comes arrive and
she's staying with the aunt who's hyper
religious
three kids but whatever fair so at this
point
they're moving in all this stuff is
happening and the girls really brought
up in a hyper religious cultural family
and their mom mom is revealed to be
really sad because she just found out
her husband
is taking on a second husband her
husband is taking on a
second husband second wife no second
wife
plopped away this is very progressive
now it's a problem that was a problem
and he takes on a second wife and
you see the mom is really torn up by
like in private and the young daughter
sees that and it really hurts her to see
her mom
having to accept the idea that her
husband is just gonna take it because of
cultural reasons
so the daughter seeing what's in store
for her what her aunt wants her to be
raised in
begins to rebel and what does she turn
to she turns to these young girls who
seem to be
independent seem to be so full of
strength and they're fighting against
the world so she joins the crew right
then they start they they start being
her they start peer pressuring her
then she starts to kind of undo the
layers
behind the group and realize these women
are actually unhappy as well
even though they're fighting for likes
some of them are being told they're good
for nothing they
have a lot of depression so she's
realizing
that getting into that life is not all
it's caught up to be
and her situation at home is getting
even worse
but she dives deeper into this stuff and
she starts to try to
use sexualizations as a means to get
things because
she wants to escape her reality so bad
and for a lot of young girls that's what
happened listen it happened to me
as a boy bruh
go ahead sorry no that's that's it but i
grew up in amazon family yeah
and do you know how many times i saw
muslim girls do the exact same thing
right the more that the mom was trying
to impress that on you you live in a
muslim family i live in a religious
family christian and everything and i've
seen the same thing on
on a sunday you was good but i mean on
saturday i saw youth work
as the story progresses and she gets
more and more depraved and she's
following
more for the likes she starts to do more
extreme stuff in order to
kind of garner that affection and you
see her descent and you see how unhappy
she is
at no point do you watch that and be
like i wish i could do that the whole
time
you feel terrible for her because you
understand she's going towards a bad
place and the climax is like
there's a performance that they're
finally going to do right
and during that performance this is what
they've been working for she realized
how unhappy she is
and there's like a whole bunch of like
african music i believe it's senegalese
music that's playing that's
really calling her back to her roots and
she just runs away and she goes back
home and her mom
tells her it's a really cool moment it's
a really subtle moment the mom tells her
you can come back in this house you
don't have to come to this wedding
you're going to be fine so the girl
changes it from her torque outfit
into a very light just regular outfits
she goes outside and she starts hop
scotching and i thought the
it was a good middle ground she didn't
have to go to that full conservative
where she has to accept a second one but
she
she accepted her kid her being a kid and
the child also accepted a sense of
modesty where she realized i didn't have
to do all of that to be accepted
and so at no point in the movie did i
feel like they were glorifying it or
making it look positive they did the
opposite
and they did it very clearly throughout
she never looked really happy or well
throughout the movie to me
did she look that way to you no never
it's a quick quick scene
but she catches one of the kid that was
in the crew that she replaced
and what did she do she comes out of the
bathroom and she she was throwing up
yeah she's a bit chubby so there's also
that the image yeah
the image so there's a lot of it's
really commentary
on what is really happening and saying
yo you can't show that you can't show
that see
exactly you see there you see there you
are uncomfortable with the
truth and sometimes being uncomfortable
is not a bad
thing yeah and i saw the post on twitter
people were just kind of like
posting like a list of like bad scenes
in this movie that
but they were out of context like the
one where she takes a picture of her
she doesn't first off they don't show
you actually her doing that
but the reason why she does that and the
reason why she goes to that length
is because she wants everyone online to
know that she doesn't have a bad crotch
because people were making fun of her
so she's going that far in order to be
liked on instagram
that scene where she's like slightly
taking off her jacket in order to
get the fold from her uncle it's showing
you how far she thinks she has to go
actually
in order to get a phone because she's so
obsessed with being admired
and at no point do i think oh this is
great you're sitting there being like
this is a terrible story it's tragic the
the worst part for me about the poster
is that they use the outfits which
revolve around the scene when the girl
has like
her moment of catharsis where she
realized what she's doing is wrong
and she decides she doesn't want to do
this kind of dance anymore and she goes
back home and she chooses a life of more
modesty instead of that
so to use her and that outfit right
before the climax
seems so counterintuitive because it's
not a representation of the movie
the thing that happened is that people
have to understand there's a lot of
scenes in the movie that are
uncomfortable
and sometimes you have to be that's what
we call
a critique of in order to critique
something
or to make a commentary of something i
have to put it in your face and show you
what i'm critiquing or else what am i
critiquing
what am i showing you i can't show you
the example
if i don't have the example itself right
it's hard to give people an idea of how
bad the cartel war is
if i don't show you pablo escobar
cutting the dude's head off if i don't
show you
him feeding a body to animals if i don't
show you kids
being shot for not being a good lookout
if i don't show you the depravity
of that event then you won't understand
how you're supposed to feel about it
when you watch it
in that same token when i watch this
movie i did not leave it thinking oh
i can't wait to watch 11 year olds do
that again i left it thinking when i
raise my kids i don't think i ever want
them to join a dance troupe
the movie is not the problem
the problem is all the things that they
talk about in the movie yes
the girl had wanting to be accepted
the girls in the social media wanting to
be
liked there's all these problems there's
a lot of times in this movie
that just girls not being the cool
person or
people not really want people not being
the cool person
and wanted to identify with the cool
crowd and doing
almost anything they can and it's kids
and it happened
the problem is not in the movie the
problem is in
actual reality and it's depicting that
oh
oh wait oh oh no i see what the problem
is you know what the problem is and why
people were mad
because in hollywood whenever they want
to depict a 16 year old or
or 15 or 13 year old they have 30 years
old uh
playing them whenever you see american
pie all these kids are supposed to be
in not even in college they're supposed
to be in high school
but you see a kid [ __ ] a pie but
because you see an adult you think it's
okay
but if you look at the story that's not
okay and it doesn't have the same impact
when you have
an older person because when i'm looking
at this 11 year old and i'm seeing what
she's doing to in order to get likes
it's showing me the links that young
children have to go and i'm seeing an
innocent child having to go to these
legs
it hits you harder i remember watching
beasts of no nation and there's a scene
where idris elba takes one of the child
soldiers and says come to my room and
basically
he's going to get one of the child
soldiers that he just used to massacre a
village to basically give him some top
and the the screen is slowly built up
you don't see anything explicitly but
you understand what he's going to do to
that child
but if it hadn't been a child the scene
would have had no impact
and so when people say you can't use a
kid in that kind of context you don't
understand one the kid is acting
two nothing is explicitly shown for the
most part and three
if you don't have a child there the
scene is meaningless
and when i'm watching narcos there has
to be kids on the lookout
because kids are the only ones who can
go there and be seen in public
and nobody backs an eye they're perfect
look it has to be them
appeal of a bear liking it is not going
to be the determining factor of when not
a movie should exist to me that's a
really backwards way
you could probably find violent
criminals who are going to like violent
movies scarface mafia whatever
does that mean that we should get rid of
those movies because it you think it
appeals to them
you know to me it's just it's not good
it's not a good strain of thought
i understand we want to protect children
and i think that is
a very important conversation to have
but you don't create a better society
for children by killing the importance
of context
the amount of people who reply to this
story or to this movie or critique the
scenes without the context
to me did something that was so
disingenuous and
rash you're really you're setting up a
society where
we don't look at the full story before
we react to things do you want to raise
your kid in that we already see how bad
that's doing
when it comes to new cycle when it comes
to politics when it comes to so many
things
we're killing context every single day
and even if it's for a good cause it's
still a very dangerous slippery slope to
go down
to all the youtubers who made all these
reviews of this movie without
watching it in full your job as a
commentary channel is to
actually do the work that your audience
won't so to me it's very lazy on your
part for you to just sit there
youtubers actually like and who do good
content we're so lazy with the response
to this movie
i'm not here to try to have an edgy
opinion i was ready to hate it yeah i
was i was
i was like oh yeah we're going in on
this you want me to watch it you want me
to watch it
i want you to slam dunk and then i watch
i'm like but i can't lie to you guys
i can't sit here and not tell you what
i'm actually thinking when i'm watching
him like
even though i don't like this movie this
is clearly not what you guys are
claiming it is
i think i think it's a i i thought it
was a good movie yeah i'm gonna tell you
like that because it depicts
reality it's an 11 year old and they
look
11. and that's cringy um on the point
that by using young children in order to
do these roles they are inherently doing
that which they
are trying to argue against i would say
this
one can be for a peaceful world and
still understand that sometimes war is
necessary in that same token
these young girls participate in a
project which they felt
really told the story that fought
against something that they have to deal
with every day
and sometimes portraying that maybe the
best way to visually show everyone
that this is wrong i think this movie
does a better job
of displaying why these things are bad
than saying oh this is exploitation and
i think you cannot
really showcase just how bad it is and
to what degree these young ladies go
through it
without having young ladies actually
playing those roles i know you'd like to
believe that older actors can do it but
just like in beasts of no nation
you really have to have young kids who
look like they have
full of innocence doing these actions to
realize how bad it was
it's dumb i understand people didn't
want to watch it because what they'd
seen before
was so polarizing and looked so bad that
you probably didn't want to give this
movie
a chance or to even look into it but i
can't understand but i can't judge it if
i didn't watch it
fair fair that's it i probably just
wouldn't have commented on the movie
personally
let's have that discussion about the
over sexualization of young children
let's have that conversation it's worth
having
in having that conversation let's not
just be reactive and throw everything
under the bus
this kind of hyper protective society
that we're trying to create
has made it so that men feel
uncomfortable around young children i
don't even want to be around a kid
because people go so crazy do you know
how many times i've received the topic
why won't they allow males at um
daycares and so many women just post i
would never
leave my kid at a daycare where a man is
present this is the kind of society that
we fostered where
we are so hyper vigilant that everything
seems like a
threat to kids and while i know we have
to do a better job of protecting kids
and it's necessary
we also have to be careful that there
may be a cost to this
and can we just talk about it instead of
being like you know what i'm outraged
let's cancel
instead of doing that you don't want to
have a conversation about any of the
problems
that was depicted in the movie and
that's what i have a problem with you
let us know what you think is we want to
hear
uh your perspective and if you haven't
seen the movie
maybe you check it out or don't
man